jobs growth soars Joe Biden goes off on
a townhall questioner and the Democrats
long slog Zwarte impeachment continues
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show today's show is sponsored by
expressive VPN hell are you waiting for
this is how my listener secured that are
gonna and you should to join them and
express it VPN calm / Ben okay well lots
of news to get to today a lot of it in
the 2020 presidential race most of it
just demonstrative of the fact that our
politics come on guys it's fun it's fun
we've got presidential candidates who
are out there on the campaign trail
yelling at people in the crowd about how
fat and stupid presidential candidates
whose followers are trying to hit other
people with canes I mean this is good
stuff this is America America was
already great speaking of America
already being great the economy
continues to be extremely strong under
President Trump there is a a new jobs
report out today according to CNBC calm
the jobs market turned in a stellar
performance in November with non-farm
payrolls surging by 266,000 the
unemployment rate fell again to three
point five percent which is effectively
full employment according to the Labor
Department numbers released this Friday
by the way the number of people who are
in the jobs market is now back to
pre-recession levels in terms of
percentages which is a great thing these
totals easily beat the Wall Street
consensus economists surveyed by Dow
Jones had been looking for a solid job
growth of about 187,000 they saw the
unemployment rate holding steady from
October's three point six percent the
decline in November's jobless rate came
amid a corresponding 0.1 percentage
point drop in the labor force
participation rates to sixty three point
two percent stocks opened sharply higher
in reaction to the better than expected
report and bond yields also surged Larry
Summers director of the National
Economic Council said bottom line
America is working these are very strong
numbers these are happy numbers these
are sunny Friday numbers this was the
best job growth since January's three
hundred and twelve thousand by the way
we are in year eleven of the recovery
your eleven of the recovery which you
know it does suggest usually America
hits a recession every decade or so and
we had one in 2000-2001 we had one in
2007-2008 we had one in 1992 so this has
been an extremely long recovery part of
the reason for that is because it was a
very slow recovery at the beginning
under
rock obama who obviously constricted the
ability of that recovery to grow so
you've had said this long slow climb as
opposed to the explosive growth they've
sometimes seen in the aftermath of other
recessions with that said these are very
very good numbers the jobs growth again
was the best since January while hopes
were already up much of that was based
on the return of GM workers following a
lengthy strike that dynamic did indeed
boost employment and Motor Vehicles and
parts by 40 1300 part of an overall
54,000 gain in manufacturing and
manufacturing is doing quite well right
now and people are in a good mood right
people are out and they're buying and
they're getting ready for Christmas
the job gains were spread of only a
multitude of sectors health care added
45,000 positions after contributing just
12,000 in October it's always funny and
whenever we discuss the government
takeover of health care very few people
actually discuss what happens to the
millions of health care workers who are
in the health care sector that is much
derided and put upon like what happens
to all those health insurance workers do
they just magically pick up jobs of the
government the answer of course is no
leisure and hospitality increased by
45,000 professional and business
services rose by 31,000 the two sectors
respectively are up 219,000 and 278,000
over the past 12 months wage gains were
also a touch better than expectations
average hourly earnings rose by 3.1
percent from a year ago which is a very
solid statistic the average work week
held steady at 34 point 4 hours so all
this talk the hear from Democrats about
people are having to work two jobs to
make ends meet well if they were then
the average work week would not be
thirty four point four hours and the
fact is Americans are working less for
more they're working less for more pay
than they were 30 40 years ago
economists have been looking for wage
gains of 3% a separate gauge of
unemployment that includes discouraged
workers and the underemployed declined
as well following 26.9% one tenth of a
percentage point below October
also there are retroactive revisions on
the economy September's estimate went up
at 13,000 to 193 thousand jobs gained
the initial October count increased by
28,000 to 156 thousand jobs gained those
changes added 41,000 to the previous
tallies and brought thee to 2019 at
monthly average to 180 thousand compared
with 223,000 in 2018 Toni Benecke in his
head of global markets for Citizens Bank
he said this is a blowout number
economy continues to be all about the
jobs the unemployment rate is at a
50-year low and wages are increasing
business owners may be getting more
cautious due to trade and political
uncertainty growth may be slow but
consumers keep spending the punchbowl
still seems full this is the lowest
jobless rate in the United States since
1969 the US economy only needs to create
about one hundred and seven thousand
jobs a month to keep that unemployment
rate steady according to the Atlanta
Federal Reserve today's job report more
than any other report in recent months
squashed any lingering concerns about an
imminent recession in the United States
economies had GAD Lebanon head of the
conference boards labor market Institute
employment growth also shows no signs of
slowing further
despite the historically low
unemployment rate now there are there
are sort of shadows of some bad news
here so for example retail companies
only added a couple thousand net hires
as gains in general merchandise of
22,000 and motor and vehicle parts
dealers of 8,000 were offset by an
18,000 loss in clothing and clothing
accessories in other words online
businesses are really having a serious
impact on the retail sector but the
recession fears that have been surging
seem to be waning just a little bit now
how much of this is due to the Fed
loosening rates hey it's hard to tell I
mean the Fed continues to loosen rates
in the in the midst of a very solid
economy but this is obviously very good
news for the President of the United
States almost 160 million people
employed in the United States this is
the 24th record breaker for president
Trump according to CNS news the
unemployment rate as I say has is now at
a 50-year low the civilian
non-institutionalized states is 260
million that includes all people 16 and
older who don't live in an institution
like prison nursing home long-term care
facility 164 million of those people are
participating in the labor force meaning
that they either had a job or are
actively seeking one during the last
month's we've got a labor force
participation rate of sixty three point
two percent the labor force
participation rate has never been higher
than sixty seven point three percent
which was a level last achieved in 2000
the Trump era high was set last month at
sixty three point three percent
economists say that a lot of retiring
baby boomers are accounting for some of
the decline since the turn of the
century I mean the numbers are just
astonishing the November unemployment
rates among adult men are 3.2 percent
3.2% among adult women teenagers only
12% unemployment rate a 3.2 percent
unemployment rate among whites a 5.5
unemployment rate among blacks a 2.6
percent unemployment rate among Asians
demonstrating once again that Asian
privilege is not a myth and Hispanics
are at 4.2 percent it's showing little
or no change in November very very big
numbers
for President Trump now what they should
say to you is that Trump should be
absolutely crushing his opposition in
the polls with an economy that is this
strong Trump should be running away with
this right the fact is that he is an
incumbent president with incredible
economic numbers to brag about also he
stacked the federal judiciary also on
foreign policy he strengthened the
United States military Trump should be
running away with this thing he is not
according to the polling numbers which
forces you to ask the question just why
and does that put the Democrats in good
position or are they a little bit weaker
than the media seems to assume we'll get
to all of that in just one second first
he talked about something I spend an
enormous amount of time in front of
screens probably so do you write I mean
I spent time in front my computer in
front of these cameras I'm spending time
in front of TV at home on my phone
I mean I'm wedded to technology one of
the things that happens we spend a lot
of time in front of screens you can sort
of get this eye strain your eyes start
to hurt well not since I've been wearing
Felix gray blue light glasses Felix gray
launched in 2016 with the singular focus
to offer the most effective computer
glasses on the market with all the
quality of brand-name designer frames
and it quickly became the Internet's
favorite blue light glasses Felix Greg
glasses filter out 90% of high-energy
blue light and eliminate 99% of the
harsh glare coming from the screens
unlike other brands who use cheap blue
light coating that are ineffective they
can chip or they can scratching at the
bubbles looking on them Felix gray uses
a proprietary blue light technology that
is embedded directly in the lens they're
available in prescription
non-prescription and readers felix grey
has got you covered with the optical
glasses for work and sleep glasses in
the evening that are clinically proven
to increase melatonin secretion when
worn leading up to bed times you fall
asleep more easily why would I buy
glasses from a company whose sole focus
is not making glasses I wouldn't that's
why I trust Felix at grade this is all
they do Felix red glasses calm slash Ben
get a pair of blue light glasses from
the pros shipping and returns totally
free so got nothing to lose
that's Felix gray glasses calm fel ix
GRA why Felix gray glasses
calm /ban felix great glasses calm / pen
okay so as I say President Trump should
be running away with this thing
but according to the Real Clear Politics
polling average he is not if you look at
the national numbers the fact is that
Trump's national numbers are not
particularly good the general election
polls show him trailing pretty much
everyone and by fairly significant
numbers the last polls that I've seen
were from lasted maybe about two weeks
ago week and a half ago from survey USA
that poll showed Biden leading Trump by
13 points Sanders leading Trump by 12
Warren leading it by seven Buddha judge
by seven even Kamala Harris was leading
him by five she's not even in the race
anymore and if you look at the at the
general national polls then what you
tend to see is is exactly this Trump is
competitive in some of them he is
utterly uncompetitive in others of them
but overall overall the Democrats seem
to have a bit of an advantage at least
in sort of the National polling numbers
now Trump can lose the national polls
and still win the election he can do
that fairly easily he lose by three or
four million popular votes of all those
votes are stats in California in New
York and that's what happened last time
right now he is running extremely
competitive in exactly those
battleground states that he was
extremely competitive than last time
and not a single battleground state in
the United States is worse off
economically than one from took office
which is a hell of a strong pitch what
does that mean
it means that if the election becomes a
referendum on Trump's personality he's
in trouble but if the referendum is on
anything else if it's on the economy and
if it's on the Democrats the Democrats
are in serious serious trouble it is why
virtually every elections sort of
statistical analysis shows that if Trump
were generic Republican he would be up
ten points right now he'd be in the mid
50's with these economic numbers he's
not he's in the low 40s in terms of
approval rating and even in the best
national polls for him when he defeats
Democrats it's very narrowly it's like
48 47 in the battleground states and
he's never winning 52% of the vote
he's always winning like 49 48 percent
of the vote a lot of that is due to
personality but here's the thing all of
that is also predicated on him having no
opponent and the Democrats they've got
some personality flaws they got some
personality problems and never a word of
those on better display then yesterday
now as I've been saying for a long time
the best option for the Democrats
don't mean to strategize in favor of
people who I hope lose but Joe Biden is
the best option for the Democrats he's
the best option for the Democrats for a
simple reason he's not alive being not
alive is a real advantage in the
selection because inanimate object
versus trump means it's a referendum on
Trump because he'll what do you think
about this Cup it's great its cup
inanimate objects dead bodies they're
just they're their objects their things
and so people don't have strong opinions
about them that's sort of how people
feel about Joe Biden generally it's all
baked into the cake in the same way that
it's bacon baked into the cake for Trump
also he doesn't seem as scary as the
other candidates by Trump his reelection
is gonna be based largely on him
pointing at people like Sanders and
Warren and saying listen we have the
best economy in American history going
right now you want to turn that over to
these gooks you want like I don't care
what you think of me you really want
Elizabeth Warren in charge of this
economy you don't take this economy and
you want to just trash it turn it over
to her and you can say the same thing
about Sanders Buddha judge is not as
scary but Buddha judge his ideas are
eventually going to come out and it
turns out that he's fairly radical as
well
Biden by contrast doesn't seem too scary
he's old he's kind of doddering he
doesn't seem to have these same sort of
radical ideas he doesn't seem like he's
gonna be particularly effective as
president and man's in your octogenarian
and so the fact that he is unscary is
exactly what cuts in his favor
there's only one problem for Joe Biden
which is that he happens to be Joe Biden
his best option would be to play dead
right now really I mean I understand yes
to win primaries and all of that but the
fact is that the Democratic population
sort of feels the same way about this
that my analysis suggests that most
Americans feel about this which is why
Joe Biden continues to lead in the race
even though he can no longer speak
English between Nancy Pelosi Donald
Trump and Joe Biden I am Not sure I mean
we definitely have to establish English
as a national language I think just so
our politicians speak it because as we
will see none of these people speak
English and I'll be honest with you I'm
very much looking forward to debate
between Donald Trump and Joe Biden
mainly because it's gonna be it's gonna
be a debate between the Swedish Chef
from the Muppets and Chewbacca
I think nobody's gonna know what's being
separate to me really amusing it's just
gonna be Donald Trump one herder and Joe
back it'll be it'll be great I'm looking
forward to it I'll explain
in just one moment first let's talk
about a movie that you should go see
this weekend so you're always lamenting
I'm always lamenting the fact that there
is no conservative content coming out of
Hollywood nothing even remotely
approaching reasonable content usually
coming out of Hollywood and that means
that when there is good content coming
out of Hollywood you should go see it
know safe spaces you should go see it
this weekend it's starring Adam Carolla
and Dennis Prager it's in theaters
nationwide Friday December 6th as in
today Adam and Dennis take you on a wild
ride to show you the effects of
political correctness identity politics
and cancel culture no safe spaces shows
why free speech is important in a free
society how it's being threatened and
what we can do to fight back it also
takes you behind the scenes on a couple
of my speeches takes you behind the
scenes my 2017 Berkeley speech where the
university had to spend six hundred
thousand dollars on security because
Antipa decided to show up and make
trouble
outside it's not your typical
documentary it's got animation and
reenactments and recreations it's a
young dennis prager is pretty funny it
also features a bunch of other voices
that you love people like jordan
peterson and brett weinstein even Cornel
West and Obama and Van Jones show up
it's a film you should take your liberal
friends to go see because if we can't
agree the free speech is important we
can't agree on anything
check them out this weekend no safe
spaces rated pg-13 it's in theaters
Friday December 6th go to no safe spaces
calm / ban for ticket information and
theater locations ok so as I say Joe
Biden is the safest pick for the
Democrats and you know even even his
sort of shortcomings I don't think
actually cut against him I will say that
I mean he's old and he's slow but he's
angry and militant yesterday there is
the this is it's the perfect
encapsulation of what our of what our
elections have become a bunch of a bunch
of Silent Generation people yelling at
each other and challenging each other to
two feats of manhood so Joe Biden gets
into it with this portly gentleman who
apparently is an Elizabeth Warren
supporter shows up at one of his events
in Iowa and this portly Elizabeth Warren
supporter questions Joe Biden about his
son Hunter Biden it and suggest the Joe
Biden is corrupt because Joe Biden
didn't do anything to stop hunter Biden
from taking jobs using his father's name
even though hunter Biden it turns out is
a is a useless narrow duo who simply
cashes in on the fact that his daddy is
very famous so Joe
I got very angry about this and proceeds
to call the man a fat old and stupid
which is no way to go through life
here's Joe Biden
[Music]
look fat look fat by the way he was this
close a fatso is he not I use this far
away he's gonna give him a peloton bike
come on come on you can't enjoy this is
because you have no sense of humor look
fat then he calls him old ok this guy's
probably 10 years Joe Biden's jr. he's
they call it look fat
but so his campaign spokesperson Symone
Sanders she comes out and she doesn't
know what he meant to say is look fat
look fat oh that's what he meant to say
not like hell he had challenged him to a
push-up contest earlier by the way if
this old dude had gotten in a push-up
contest with Joe Biden and defeated him
it would have ended Joe Biden's campaign
on the spot it would've been
unbelievably great so tip if you are a
Trump fan who wants to make Joe Biden's
candidacy obsolete somehow tempted Joe
Biden into a push-up contest and then do
it with him it would be great by the way
Joe Biden also challenged this guy to a
night huge contest Donald Trump has also
challenged people to IQ contests I am
perfectly happy and sanguine to have an
IQ contest between Donald Trump and Joe
Biden and I'm rooting for entertainment
value at this point I really am because
listen I got to cover this stuff every
day I'm a human being too and I love to
laugh so this is pretty fantastic right
he calls the guy look fat look fat now
will this launch a thousand think pieces
about how Joe Biden is calling and
Elizabeth Warren he's fat shaming fat
shaming this Elizabeth Warren supporter
horrible horrible old Joe Biden the
typical take on Twitter is that this was
somehow gonna hurt Joe Biden and the
answer is no this is not only gonna not
hurt Joe Biden it probably is gonna give
him a boost because even well I say it's
good to be a corpse every so often you
should try a sign of life sort of like
galvanizing the Frog every so often you
should have electricity shot through
just so you can appear animate and there
he looks a little bit animate right he
looks like he's alive and again Donald
Trump is President of the United States
I'm looking forward to Donald Trump who
has no sense of self-awareness saying to
Joe Biden how can how dare you fat shame
people like Donald Trump does that on a
regular basis I just I want them onstage
yelling at each other that's all I want
like they speaking of the Muppets like
like like what does it Statler and
Hofstadter who are who are in the in the
wings at the theater just yelling at
each other oh that's that's what I'm
very much looking forward to men the
portly Elizabeth Warren supporter
decided to to double down on everything
he was saying he should be running for
president - I just need a lot of I need
a lot of elderly Americans clubbing each
other and calling each other names
that's that's if we're gonna go through
this for a year we need some comic
relief
good news we are about to receive it
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about how you stay stay
healthy this holiday season so this is
the time of year when you we're gonna
put on some weight between Thanksgiving
and Christmas between the fact that it
is getting dark early which means you go
home and you just want to eat dinner and
then you wanna have a second dinner okay
the fact is if you want to stay healthy
you need to change your mental habits
how do you do that well you use an app
called Noom I've got new mitts great it
helps me keep track of my habits
it helps me track not just my calorie
count but also gives me tips and how I
can change those habits day to day so I
don't slip back into old habits
everybody who ever talks about diets
talks about how diets are a bad idea
because when you get into a diet it's
very easy to fall out of that diet and
you just go back right where you were
NUMA is about changing your life
permanently based in psychology Noom
teaches you why you do the things you do
and arms you with the tools to break the
bad habits and replace them with better
ones
Newman's a diet it's a healthy easy to
stick to way of life no food is good bad
or off-limits Noom teaches moderation
and can be used in conjunction with many
preexisting popular diets if you want so
if you're already dieting then doom is
great for you as well you don't have to
change everything in one day small steps
make big progress sign up for your trial
today at noon and
m.com / Shapiro what you have to lose
visit noon calm / Shapiro to start your
trial today that's n oom calm / appear
oh it's late last weight-loss program
you will ever need NUMA calm / Rinna
stay healthy this holiday season okay so
Iowa man right the guy who is
confronting Joe Biden it was called fat
and old for his trouble fat old and
stupid that's what Joe Biden called him
because that's where we are he is then
sitting there being interviewed by the
media afterward and another Joe Biden
supporter comes up to him who also is
probably a boomer or a member of the
Silent Generation and confronts him and
this turns into an episode of Jerry
Springer it's just spectacular this is
where we are in our politics
why don't you just get out of here
stickin up here
just creeps up behind why don't you get
it this is portly older gentleman who
supports Elizabeth Warren turned rather
sticking up your ass yep yep that's
American America yeah and then use that
this Iowa voter about Biden egos well at
least I'm not senile sure I'm old but at
least I'm not senile like Joe Biden
spectacular stuff from this guy I love
that this guy has a sense of humor about
Joe Biden saying like okay well yeah Joe
Biden got militant but at least he's
alive at least he's alive that's that's
actually gonna I'm telling you this is
gonna benefit Joe Biden if Joe Biden had
just said listen you a fat ass if you'd
really go on a form like Donald Trump
style right cuz if that's from Trump
just goes right after him right Trump
Trump doesn't even hold back well you
can see Joe Biden using at least what is
left of his prefrontal cortex to stop
himself Trump just goes right at the guy
and eviscerates him Democrats are
looking for that they are looking for
that it's actually a good moment for Joe
Biden I'll tell you what is not as good
for Joe Biden and this is this episode
is completely anti conventional wisdom
so conventional wisdom is that Joe Biden
put out an ad against President Trump
and the ad is good but that moment in
Iowa was very bad it did not show that
he was staid and solid
I think precisely the opposite yesterday
the best thing Joe Biden did was call
that dude a fatso and the worst thing he
did was release this stupid ad
suggesting that voters give a damn what
Emmanuel macron thinks of Donald Trump
so so Biden releases this ad because
Trump was at NATO and some of the other
leaders were talking bleep about Trump
behind his back and Biden releases this
ad talking about how Donald Trump is not
respected by world leaders because
that's exactly what a voter in Iowa Ohio
cares about right in Wisconsin in
Pennsylvania like oh my God if Justin
Trudeau doesn't like President Trump
what are we gonna do here was that
stupid ad world leaders caught on
cameras laughing about President
several world leaders mocking President
Trump they're laughing at him my
administration has accomplished more
than almost any administration in the
history of our country didn't expect
that reaction but that's okay if we get
Donald show four more years we'll have a
great deal of difficulty if ever being
it will recover America's standing in
the world in our capacity to bring
nations together
okay says we need a leader and so the
pod save America Bros were loving this
right the pilot of America Bros the gone
what a great ad from Joe no one cares no
one cares okay if you believe that
voters care what oh my god what did
Boris Johnson have to say about our
president no one cares about that
no body by the way I'm very much looking
forward to all of the fact checkers
suggesting that that ad needs to be fact
checked and pulled down
why because guess what Joe Biden did in
that ad so there's a clip of Donald
Trump talking about how we've
accomplished more than any other
president has at this point and then
there's this sort of rich laughter that
comes from the audience they cut that
and actually cut it they manipulated the
video because originally there were like
a couple of people who laughed and then
Trump said I wasn't expecting that and
then there was a big laugh at what Trump
said okay but they actually cut big
laugh in front of Trump's laugh line
before Trump's laugh line so fake news
right fake news but I don't think
there's gonna be an overwhelming call to
ban Joe Biden's ad on that basis to you
okay meanwhile speaking of things that
were bad for Joe Biden so again I think
that ads not great for Joe Biden I think
that him calling a dude a fatso at an
event is actually kind of good for Joe
Biden because this is our modern
politics it shows authenticity it shows
it shows that Joe Biden ain't gonna be
knuckle in under to anybody the other
bad thing for Joe Biden is the John
Kerry endorsed him yesterday we'll get
to that in just one second first let's
talk about cryptocurrency for just a
second now listen if you've never heard
anything about cryptocurrency it sounds
kind of scary right I mean you hear it's
crypto or it's okay but what exactly is
cryptocurrency effectively speaking it
is just a currency that cannot be
manipulated by central governments the
idea is that if you are living in the
United States and you have savings in
the US dollar and the US dollar starts
to inflate well then your savings have
been reduced in the in the amount that
they actually hold this is true for
countries all around the world
cryptocurrency
kind of like gold and can't be
multiplied so cryptocurrency is
protected by blockchain and the idea is
if a lot of people invest in
cryptocurrency then this is what lends
it its value and because of blockchain
you can't have people who are
duplicating it or creating more of it it
is a it is a assets that has a solid
value base specifically because it is
exclusive in the market that's what
crypto is designed to do George Gilder
writes about this at length if you're
interested in checking out
cryptocurrency the best place to do that
is
Torro eToro smart cryptocurrency made
easy eToro social trading platform has
over 11 million traders and facilitates
over a trillion dollars in trading
volume per year globally you can access
the world's best cryptocurrencies they
got 15 different coins available low and
transparent fees try before you trade
with a virtual portfolio with $100,000
budget never miss a trading trend with
charts and pricing alerts as well again
cryptocurrency is definitely worth
looking at if you're looking at precious
metals for example cryptocurrency is an
interesting alternative sign up today at
eToro comm slash capiro that's et oro
comm slash up hero eToro comm slash up
arrow and what I really like is you can
go check it out before you try it right
but that virtual portfolio eToro comm
slash up here I'll go check them out
right now ok so things that are bad for
Biden the that international had no one
cares about it also john kerry endorsed
him yesterday it's not a shock because
john kerry and joe biden's sons work
together and they're very close it
started in a venture capital firm
together that was doing business in
places like China and Ukraine and so
John Kerry endorsed Joe Biden I'm mainly
excited about that because I do a fairly
good John Kerry impersonation and now I
get to break it out again but to elderly
non non exciting candidates endorsing
each other is not exactly something that
you want to tell hey was everybody vying
for the wanted John Kerry endorsement
here so John Kerry puts out a statement
is I believe Joe Barton is the president
of our country does brilliant needs
right now not because I've known Joe so
long but because I know Joe so Wow
through it all I've seen dro tested in
public service and tested in life itself
or know his character I know the measure
of a person who never stopped fighting
for millions of Americans come on out
here Joe show him you're alive hi
everybody
John I am so exact yeah yep so in any
case is any of this a true threat to
Trump I think the problem for the
Democrats is not as much as they would
like I mean like I think Joe Biden has a
shot against Trump you look at the polls
and it's hard to say he doesn't have a
shot against Trump but by the same token
is he exciting like the good news for
him is he's boring and he's
non-threatening the bad news for him is
that he excites nobody so you
gonna have to hope that the Democratic
base hates Trump so much that they show
up to vote for Biden Democrats kind of
counted on that in 2016 it didn't work
out terrifically well for them it may
not work out that well for them in the
aftermath of impeachment if impeachment
ends up just kind of dying a quiet death
then you could see some pretty some
pretty disillusioned Democratic
supporters and if all of these woke
candidates these progressive candidates
drop out you could see exactly the
Bernie effect in 2016 there are a lot of
Bernie Sanders voters who did not show
up to the polls to vote for Hillary
Clinton last time around and I will note
that again the this race is becoming fun
because everybody is going wild and
crazy there's a Buddha judge event in
the last couple of days a couple of
black folks in South Bend Indiana
decided to put together an event in
favor of Peabody judge and a white
probably boomer decides to get up and
lecture the black lives matter
protesters that well he's a black lives
matter protester he decides to get up in
the lecture of the the black supporters
of Peabody judge that's not the part
that I'm pointing to here if we're
talking about fun in American politics
I'm talking about the lady in the front
row who you will see or hear here
getting up and waving her cane at this
guy trying to smack him with the cane
that's American politics presidential
candidates who call other fat old people
fat and old fat old people who tell
other fat old people to stick it up
their ass well elderly people trying to
smack each other with their canes does
it feel like we're in the last days here
maybe a little bit here's here's a
little bit this video of a lady trying
to smack a dude with hurricane because
she's mad at him
yes people are grabbing her coat from
and they're laughing look at the ladies
gravity police code for behind she's
laughing actually this is funny we're
gonna smack this guy down with the cane
yeah America everything's going great
over here and most powerful free country
in world history smacking each other
with their canes call each other fat and
old good times good times
but we can always count on the youth of
our country to save us right because
it's not like we would use children as
props or anything
speaking of using children as props and
people who judge so last night Peter
Budaj judge held an event and a
seven-year-old girl got up and asked
people to judge about my body my choice
really because that's not now this puts
out this video of course because nothing
is more charming than small children
asking about the killing of the unborn
in the womb very very exciting stuff you
sound pretty sophisticated for a child
do you mind if I ask how old do you are
how old are you sir really well you're
ahead of your time what I hope everybody
or at least most of us can agree on is
who gets to draw the line and that's the
person making the decision that's the
woman and little girl if your mommy had
decided that you just weren't worth it
Wow
now open it for you people who judge
talking abortion with seven-year-olds
just just delightful by the way the
media is starting to turn on Peabody
judge here because the media are very
angry they thought Elizabeth Warren had
a clear path to the nomination it turns
out that nobody likes her plans and the
more they see of Elizabeth Warren the
less they like her and so people who
judge has surged in the polls
well now the media are going after
people who judge and going after people
who to judge hard they're going after
him from the left they're suggesting
that Peabody judge is a corrupt
capitalist crony I'll get to that in
just one second first let's talk about
the fact that the Second Amendment is
deeply necessary why well not only do
you want to protect yourself and your
family you also want to protect your
freedoms this is why the Second
Amendment was created in the first place
now folks on the Left get very
when you say things like this you mean
the American people should be able to
arm themselves in case of violation of
their most profound rights yes that's
what the American Revolution was about
that's what the Constitution explicitly
is about that's what it is about yeah
that doesn't mean anyone is calling for
violence right now that doesn't mean
that violence will be justified it does
mean that one of the things that keeps
America a rights-based country is an
armed population everyone who studies
the Second Amendment knows this you know
who else knows this the people over at
Bravo Company manufacturing they know
that owning a rifle is an awesome
responsibility building rifles is no
different started in a garage by a
Marine veteran more than two decades ago
Bravo Company manufacturing BCM for
short builds a professional-grade
product built to combat standards Bravo
Company manufacturing is not a sporting
arms company they design engineer
manufacture life-saving equipment the
people of BC I'm assume that when a
rifle leaves their shop it will be used
in a life-or-death situation by a
responsible citizen law enforcement
officer or a soldier overseas to learn
more about Bravo company manufacturing
head on over to Bravo Company MFG comm
where you can discover more about their
products special offers and upcoming
news that's Bravo Company MFG comm if
you need more convincing find out even
more about BCM and the awesome people
they really are great who make their
products at youtube.com slash Bravo
Company USA that's youtube.com slash
Bravo Company USA great folks go check
them out right now okay it is that
glorious time of the week when I give a
shout-out to a daily wire subscriber who
is it is it you know it's Instagram or
Trudy
Goldberg piers who works at a place
surrounded by raging leftists and
understands there is only one beverage
vessel that can help sustain you through
such troubled times in this picture
Trudy's majestic left his tears tumbler
sits on a kitchen table propping up a
Harvard class of 2020 announcement the
caption reads thanks for men who left
his tears tumblr and thanks for all you
do you guys give me the strength to hold
my head up high
every day at Kremlin on the Charles I
know I've been there I've been there
fantastic always glad to know there are
more of us lurking around Harvard who
aren't zombified into the leftist
rudimentary z-- thanks for the picture
thanks for your support if you're not
already subscribe or you're really
missing out head on over to daily
wire.com slash subscribe for as little
as ten bucks a month you get our
articles had free access to all of our
live broadcast our full show library
select bonus contents our exclusive
daily guar app which is pretty great
feature if you haven't checked it out
yet if you choose the new All Access
plan you'll get all of that plus the
legendary leftist your tumblr and
our brand-new ask me anything a style
discussion feature that allows you to
engage our hosts writers special guests
on a weekly basis oh stop depriving
yourself come join the fun it's a Friday
that would be a great time to buy
yourself that subscription in advance of
Christmas or do it for others in advance
of Christmas or Hanukkah we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so this field is desperately thin and
the media are turning on people to judge
they don't like people to judge they're
very upset that Kamala Harris is out
there upset that all of the woe
candidates have been falling off the
side of the road and now they're very
angry at Buddha judge so the New York
Times editorial board has a full piece
today called Buddha judges untenable vow
of silence they're very angry at him
because Buddha judge worked for nearly
three years for the consulting firm
McKinsey & Company
okay let's face this I know a lot of
folks were just like people who judge
when I was at Harvard Law School there
were twenty you know I would say 50% of
the class was like people to judge
meaning highly intelligent people who
went into consulting sort of down the
line liberals in terms of government
spending but not overtly and deeply
anti-capitalism
not explicitly anti the American system
they weren't they weren't people trying
to tear down free markets from the
inside out they just sort of wanted to
curb the reach of free markets and sort
of where people judge used to be and
it's where in his better moments he sort
of lives but this is where the New York
Times hates him because the left has
moved left Peabody judge as of 2011 was
not this and when he was working at
McKinsey which again is a is a very very
famous consulting company McKinsey does
business management and they do it for a
lot of clients that sort of toe tag
liberals don't necessarily like so the
New York Times angry at him they say
people who judge work nearly three years
for the consulting firm McKinsey and
company he has presented that experience
as a kind of capitalist credential
distinguishing him from some rivals for
the Democratic presidential nomination
they'll try the socialist thing Booty
judge told an Iowa audience in September
so but the thing is I got started in the
private sector
the thing is says the New York Times
Budaj Edge has had precious little about
his time in McKinsey he's not named the
clients for whom he worked nor said much
about what he did he says his lips are
sealed by an NDA he signed when he left
the firm in 2010 and that he has asked
the company to release him from the
agreement it has not yet agreed to do so
this is not a tenable situation who to
judge those voters and more complete
accounts of his time at the company
promoters sinking an alternative to
trump should demand the candidates not
only reject Trump's positions but also
his behavior including his refusal to
share information about his health and
his business dealings this standard
requires Budi judge to talk about his
time at McKinsey it similarly requires
Biden and Bernie Sanders to stop
dragging their feet and release their
health records to the public
the obligation to provide more
information ultimately falls on Buddha
jet she must find a way to give voters a
more complete accounting of his time at
the company this is a coordinated hit by
the way the Huffington Post has a
similarly large article about the Buddha
judge and people who judges
unwillingness to turn over all the
information about Mackenzie Buddha judge
for his part says I didn't do anything
when I was hit McKenzie nothing I worked
on spreadsheets and powerpoints okay
well sure sure you did
sure day for whom for which clients
would they be clients than Elizabeth
Warren would be happy with by the way
Elizabeth Warren is leading this charge
she's basically using the the editors
over the New York Times and Huffington
Post as meat puppets at this point she
criticizes Buddha judge for not being
transparent enough about Mackenzie and
then they immediately start parroting
that message here's booty judge saying
nothing to see here nothing to see here
just keep moving move along move along
these are not the droids you're looking
for this is my first job out of school
it mostly consisted of preparing
spreadsheets and powerpoints but I would
be happy to be able to share more about
the the consulting work that I did is
there anybody that you regret
representing no did you ever represent a
foreign government no a pharmaceutical
company no and again I'm hoping that
we'll get a chance to just be able to
push all this out okay so the I'm sure
he's waiting and hoping for that or
alternatively he's not waiting and
hoping for that at all but the media are
coming after Budi dredge and his little
surge lit here I think that it's gonna
come to an end sometime in the near
future meanwhile Elizabeth Warren
continues to try it out her insanely
radical plans this is why Joe Biden is
the front-runner
Joe Biden may be old he may have the
endorsement of John Kerry he may put out
weird ads about how Emmanuel macron
doesn't like Trump but at least he ate
this hey Elizabeth Warren is putting out
economic plans predicated on the notion
that tax increases themselves will help
the economy there is no evidence that
this is true none that tax increases
that not even how you spend the money
not even how you spend the money just
the taking of the money from the top
tier if you just take it from the top
tier this creates extra income equality
and this prompts economic growth
hey this exact philosophy was not
exactly a balloon for the USSR Cuba or
Venezuela and whenever you how you
spending the money is the question
money is merely a means of exchange if
you exchange it for nothing you have
destroyed
Capital value okay but according to
Elizabeth Warren in the New York Times
maybe that's all hackneyed nonsense
maybe we have a brand new vision of
economics if Trump runs against this he
will wipe the floor with this
perspective the New York Times has a
piece called good tax increases speed up
the economy Democrats say yes
led by Elizabeth Warren presidential
candidates and liberal economists are
pushing an unorthodox pro-growth
argument for raising taxes on the rich
now if you're making the Keynesian
argument that if you take money from
rich people give it to poor people and
the poor people are more likely to spend
and the spending crates of multiplier
effect in the economy and this is gonna
lead to bottom-up growth has an argument
that's been tried it's not true it
doesn't work okay we tried it during the
Great Depression it lengthened the Great
Depression by full-on eight years but at
least that is an argument that has data
to back it up at least you can make an
argument sort of maybe it's not a good
argument you can make it the argument
that you can just take money from rich
people and then burn it and that that's
going to somehow help the economy that's
a purely insane argument I mean that's
crazy a no democratic before miss Warren
has ever proposed so many new taxes and
spending programs and so lean lean so
heavily into the argument that they
would be in economist parlance
pro-growth according to the New York
Times that argument tries to reframe a
classic debate about the economic pie in
the United States by suggesting there is
no trade-off between increasing the size
of the pie and dividing the slices more
equitably among all Americans and this
this article actually suggests on the
basis of no evidence none that if you
just take money away from rich people
and you give it to other people it does
not matter how they spend the money the
mere taking away of the money is what is
going to actually create the growth
that's full-on nuts that's full-on crazy
towns as I say the other argument that
sort of redistributionist argument the
bottom-up debate demand-side argument
which is a bad economic argument there's
a supply side and demands had argument
about economics the supply side says
that what creates economic growth is
entrepreneurs creating new products you
didn't even know that you wanted and
then you want that product and so you
have to trade your labor for that
product that creates new jobs right that
is the supply side economic argument the
demand side economic argument is you if
people who are lower down have more
money they spend more money on
hamburgers and McDonald's has more jobs
it's not a particularly good argument it
tends to stagnate the economy rather
than creating
exactly the sort of new products and
services and competition that you want
but now there's a new argument being
made that Democrats are making that it
does not matter how you spend the money
at all it does not matter I mean that
which is a again a wild contention
completely crazy based on absolutely
nothing based on absolutely nothing nor
Rothman has a great piece at commentary
magazine talking about how confiscating
wealth is the point right there further
Democrats it is not about how the wealth
is spent or creating the wealth it is
the it is the attempt to steal the
wealth that is the point nor often
quotes the New York Times generations of
economists across much of the
ideological spectrum have long held that
higher taxes reduce investments slowing
economic growth miss Warren other
leading Democrats say the opposite
Rothman points out it doesn't take long
before it becomes clear that
progressives have not come to overturn
the accumulated wisdom of many lifetimes
of study and application the financial
ramifications associated with
expropriating private property are a
secondary concern the confiscation of
wolf alone is the point of the
progressive enterprise The Times
observes some liberal economists go
further and say that simply taxing the
rich would help growth no matter what
the government did with the money ok
that's it again based on nothing Trump
will run against this and win one
hundred times out of 100 times which is
again why Joe Biden continues to lead in
this race meanwhile I do love the fact
that Cory Booker is still standing in
the wind shouting at the remember me I'm
black guy I'm the only black person in
the race guys I'm so black remember look
at me here my angry eyes I'm very upset
that there are no other black people in
the if you like black people I know one
it's me says Cory Booker here he is it
is a problem that we now have a overall
campaign for the 2020 presidency that
has more billionaires in it than black
people I've seen folk here in Iowa Bulai
what what all the predictions are it was
this state that set a trajectory for the
first black man in American history to
become president uh well okay so his
pitches that comel Harris is out and if
you want somebody black I'm your man
that's that's a that's a pitch who me
and cast are doing the same thing he's
Hispanic so that means that you should
vote for him not a great pitch and
meanwhile you can see why Democrats are
so reliant on impeachment you can see
why they're trying to move forward with
this impeachment even though they don't
actually have the evidence for it so
Nancy Pelosi is already saying that the
house is gonna draft up impeachment
charges and that this thing is going to
happen maybe before Christmas there
could be a vote before Christmas to
charge him with high crimes and
misdemeanors then it goes to the Senate
okay so Nancy Pelosi yesterday went nuts
you can see that she feels like she's
the the grip is slipping here right
Pelosi as she walks off stage has this
crazed moment it really is a crazed
moment and don't give me the it's sexist
to call it Christ that's absolute bull
crap okay Howard Dean how to yell it
ended his presidential campaign so if
the idea is that acting crazy is bad for
you politically then that should apply
to Nancy Pelosi also this is a crazy
moment and somebody says to her isn't
the real reason that you Democrats are
going at like there are people who
suggest including actual Republicans in
Congress that the reason Democrats are
going after Trump is because they hate
him which I mean fairly good evidence
fairly gonna isn't is that why this is
happening and Pelosi turns around and
says to James Rosen works for Sinclair
broadcasting she turns around and she
says to him I'm a Catholic Catholics
don't hate people by the way what a
solid Catholic she is abortion up till
points of birth here is Nancy Pelosi
being very upset as a Catholic that
someone used the word hate to describe
her
I asked a question this is about the
Constitution of the United States and
the facts that lead to the president's
violation of zones of office and as a
Catholic I resent you're using the word
hate in a sentence that addresses me I
don't hate anyone I was raised in a way
that is full a heart full of love and
always prayed for the president oh she
prays for Trump yeah and if you believe
that when I got a bridge I can sell you
in Brooklyn it's really nice comes cheap
Trump and tweeted out Nancy Pelosi just
had a Vera it had a nervous fit she
hates that we will soon have 182 great
new judges and so much more stock market
and unemployment records she says she
prays for the president I don't believe
her not even close
help the homeless in your district Nancy
USMC a and that is the the trade deal
that Trump is trying to push through
Pelosi doubled down on this she said it
was disgusting disgusting to be asked if
she hates Trump because as a good
Catholic who supports the idea that men
can become women in women men as a good
Catholic who believes that same-sex
marriage should be federally mandated as
a good Catholic who believes that
abortion should be legal up to a point
of birth and maybe beyond Nancy Pelosi
is very offended that you would use the
word hate to describe her feelings about
President Trump I was raised a Catholic
my college roommate read admire my
college classmate married a beta are
here with a we we were raised and my
dear husband Paul and Demi a friend
Susan we were raised in a Catholic faith
and the word hate a person was just that
just doesn't happen you know the word
hate is a terrible word but you might
reserve it for vanilla ice cream or
something like that but not I'm a
chocoholic but not for a person and it
is so for him to say that was really
disgusting to me disgusting disgusting
disgusting it's so it's it's really it's
wild and there there's an opinion piece
by Karen's home multi over at the
Washington Post defending Nancy Pelosi
on this saying she's such a good
Catholic one of the things every
Catholic child is taught is that the
word hate should never be used in
connection with another human being this
admonition flows from the expense
of Catholic interpretation of the fifth
commandment in the general audience last
year in st. Peter's Square
Pope Francis declared it to hate is to
murder in your heart and then it talks
about Nancy Pelosi's response her
critics will question her sincerity and
point out she was broken with Catholic
teaching on big issues of doctrine chief
among them abortion the church has their
position we have ours which is that a
woman has free will given to her by God
Pelosi told the New York Times in 2015
Pope Pelosi explained but those who know
her well insists religious belief is at
the core of everything Pelosi does there
are two pillars in her life in terms of
her beliefs her Catholicism a very deep
faith and her family her friend and
fellow California congresswoman Anna
Eshoo told colleague of Paul Cain on
Thursday this is the authentic Nancy no
small part of that was the influence of
her mother a daily communicant when her
funeral was referred to as being molded
by Regina caeli the Easter prayer to
Mary my favorite part of this piece by
the way is the is the admission by Karen
Tumulty that she actually understands
what religious people believe she'll
only apply to Nancy Pelosi however she
says disgust to a Catholic is not the
same as hatred as Pelosi and Pelosi
noted political differences should be
resolved in the 2020 election so the
case that is being made here is that
Pelosi doesn't hate the president she
just has disdain for his activity she in
other words she hates the sinner but not
the sin weird that Karen Tumulty and the
rest of the folks in the left-wing press
will believe Nancy Pelosi when it comes
to President Trump but they will never
believe a religious person when they
talk about any amount of sin that a
religious person discusses there it is
motivated by animus motivated by animus
and hatred and brutality Eric's wha-whoa
when he's not advocating the nuclear
annihilation of gun owners in the United
States is not farting on national TV
Eric's wha-whoa was on MSNBC and he said
it's sexist to criticize Nancy Pelosi in
this way sexist I'm so tired this crap
seriously hey everybody in the United
States in the political sphere takes
their share of crap Nancy Pelosi Speaker
of the House woman up
here's Eric's wawel complaining that if
you thought that that was wild response
by Nancy Pelosi it's because you hate
women or something that's how they talk
about women you know if it was a man
talking to a reporter that way and the
president does that often they would
never characterize it that way she was
asked an unfair question and she gave a
response everybody nodding along on
MSNBC very solemnly oh the nodding the
nodding by the way are the Democrats
doing this because they hate Trump
here's representative Al Green
explaining there's literally no limits
to the number of times they would try to
impeach Trump Al Green has called for
Trump to be impeached pretty much every
day since he was elected a president can
be impeached more than once so we can do
this we can move forward with what we
have on the table currently we can take
this before the Senate and we can still
investigate other issues and when the
president has committed additional
offenses and my suspicion is that he
will we can take those before the Senate
there is no limit on the number of times
the Senate can vote to convict or not a
president no limit to the number of
times a house can vote to impeach or not
no limit none yes I'm sure this is all
motivated by concern over the
Constitution and not at all motivated by
any level of animus in the hearts of
Democrats at all they you know they love
Trump they just hate his sin that I
totally believe them and also I believe
that men can become women women can be
men and unicorn crap can provide all the
energy that the earth needs okay time
for some things I like and then some
things that I hate okay things that I
like today this is just a wonderful
wonderful story so remember that time
that Colin Kaepernick had a tryout and
then he decided to be like a complete
jerk and not have the NFL try to have
his own tryout and released videos about
how tough his life was and how people
are very mean to him well and where a
Kunta Kinte shirt while doing his tryout
because he's a victim just like Kunta
Kinte the character of the slave in
roots remember that well now it turns
out that one of the wide receivers who
was actually at his tryout has now
signed with the Washington Redskins so
Colin Kaepernick still does not have a
job but the receiver that he used in the
tryout does name is Jordan BC he's now
signed on with the Washington Redskins
according to Fox News the Washington
Redskins signed VZ to their practice
squad he worked out with Kaepernick last
month in Atlanta High School he caught a
50-yard pass from the former San
Francisco 49ers star it was described as
one of the quarterbacks best throws the
VC had generated some buzz with the
Cleveland Browns the wide receiver
largely credited the session with his
profession
success he says it helped that's one of
the reasons I want to be part of it just
being a part of history of it I knew it
was gonna help me I was gonna be in
Gadsden running routes anyway might as
well run him in front of some Scouts so
the great irony the people who did not
sign Colin Kapernick signed be receiver
who caught one of his passes because
that person is not an obnoxious jerk so
good news for Jordan easy and
congratulations okay time for a quick
thing that I hate okay thing that I hate
today so everybody is praising the
Irishman everybody loves this movie I
don't know how now listen I have said
before my biases are on the table
I think the Martin Scorsese is a
dramatically overrated filmmaker in fact
the only filmmaker that the only only
film that I actually really liked of his
is the one that everybody else hates
silence which is about religious faith I
think that one is actually really
interesting but he his new film the
Irishman is just interminable it is 1
million hours long it took me three days
to watch it and I understand that it's
sort of elegiac goodbye to the industry
and to the into the into this sort of
genre but that doesn't mean it's good
because it's not it's not first of all
its portrayal Jimmy Hoffa is kind of
ridiculous but beyond that the the
actual plot doesn't make any sense
it is extremely over long it's slow as
all get-out people are praising the fact
that it's it's it's basically Goodfellas
for for the Silent Generation right it's
Goodfellas just you move it forward 40
years in time and instead of ray
Liotta's character going into witness
protection he dies of old age that's
pretty much the entirety of it except
with healthy fun so here's a little bit
of the Irishman which is being receiving
all the critics awards by the way I
don't get it I don't get it except that
I understand it's Martin Scorsese we're
all gonna pretend that we like the film
even though nobody has actually made it
through the film without falling asleep
for at least 45 minutes are you Frank
would you like to be a part of history
yes
big business and the government part
working together trying to pull us apart
something's gotta be done what else you
say now's not the time to not say so
this trailer makes it look a lot more
exciting than it actually is
the performance is by De Niro and Pesci
our good
Al Pacino has been doing sensible woman
since sensible woman so that's annoying
but it'll be on everybody's top ten of
the Year list it's taken American
history by the way is kind of ridiculous
in in cynical and it just not a fan not
a fan so it does not justify your
Netflix subscription okay time for you
know what it's the end of the week
so I'm gonna do what I've been doing
most weeks now do a little bit of Bible
talks of the Jews read a portion from
the Bible every week this week's portion
comes from the book of Genesis and it
contains one of the great controversies
in all of Bible history the question of
whether Jacob stole Esau's birthright
and his blessing so these are you know
controversial events even now so Jake
Jacobs controversy begins with the birth
right very simple scenario Esau is his
brother the hunter and he comes back
from the field and he's hungry and he
demands of Jacob pour into me now some
of that very red stuff for I'm exhausted
and Jacob says sell me as of this day
your birthright to me and Esau without
hesitating says look I'm gonna die so
what have you what of what used to me is
a birthright the deal is struck and the
Torah reports that Jacob asks for Esau
so--the and Esau promptly gives it and
then the Torah adds a note Jacob gave
Esau bread and lentil stew and he ate
and drank got up and left
thus Esau spurned the birthright so
people have said for a while is this
Jacob cheating Esau or is this actually
just a fair and square deal well the
answer is really you know we mentioned
Keynesian philosophy before John Maynard
Keynes famously suggested at one point
that the that in the in the long run
everybody is dead that you shouldn't you
shouldn't think too much about the
future because in the long run everybody
is dead so instead you should deal with
the problems that are on the table right
now Keynesianism essentially argues that
is better used by poor people than by
rich people which is not particularly
good economic sense but he ignores the
fact that long-run concerns matter he
says in the long run we're all dead
which is a deeply immoral principle
right the progress of mankind is
dependent on you making sacrifices on
behalf of your children who make
sacrifices on behalf of their children
and thus for generations you have a
chain of sacrifice well in the Bible
Esau is the epitome of a short term
thinker when he says look I'm gonna die
so if you what used to me as a
birthright he's not really saying that
he's literally going to die of
starvation unless you get some lentil
soup he's articulating a basic leftist
principle which is that what matters is
my material well-being today it's not
about me sacrificing today on behalf of
tomorrow and Jacob sees this and he says
okay well the birthright matters to me
because the birthright is not about what
happens to me it's about what happens to
my kids and what happens to my kids kids
this is the major difference in the
Torah between Esau and Jacob Esau is
described as a hunter and Jacob is
described as a wholesome man abiding
intense in other words he saw lives day
today he's about going out and providing
the food on the table for today and
Jacob is the one who cultivates and
domestication and cultivation is the
essence of civilization which is why the
birthright should descend on the person
who is thinking toward the future this
is why it was kind of amazing Joe Biden
was asked about his balanced budget
amendment back in 1995 which he signed
on to and he said no we don't need a
balanced budget amendment anymore the
situation is far too immediate and far
too grave whenever people tell you that
the immediate situation is far too great
for you to think about things that are
gonna happen 10 years down the line
that's a mistake
it's a mistake it this still doesn't
answer Jacobs trickery with regard to
his father right so Jacob then tricks
his dad about all of this so Jacob has
basically a normal market exchange with
Esau for Esau his birthright is
literally not worth a bowl of soup and
Jacob knows this and so he takes the
birthright but then why does Jacob have
to somehow trick his father because when
he comes to Isaac's bedside Jacob once
again engages into sea right Isaac has
gone blind by this point he tells Esau
I've aged I don't know the day of my
death sharpen your gear your sword in
your bow go out into the field and hunt
game for me and then make me delicacies
such as I love it bring it to me and
I'll eat so my soul may bless you before
I die and then obviously Rebekah
believes that
saw is a bad guy and Jacobs a good guy
so she covers Jacob up with kind of
rough skins to imitate Esau she cooks up
the gourmet meal for Isaac justice Isaac
atoll he sought to do and then she sends
Jacob in to see Isaac and Isaac
immediately recognizes something's up he
says who are you my son and Jacob says
that he's Esau but Isaac still doesn't
really believe that he says how is it
that you were so quick to find my son
meaning how did you make this food so
fast and Jacob gives an answer that's
pretty clear that he isn't he saw he
says because your God arranged it for me
it's very out of character for Esau to
credit God and so Isaac gets even more
suspicious he says come close if you
please so I can feel you my son are you
indeed my son Esau or not and when Jacob
draws closer Isaac says the voice is
Jacob's voice but the hands are Esau his
hands and he blesses him anyway so in
other words Isaac knows something's up
and then a few minutes later Esau shows
up and Isaac doesn't know who he is but
when Esau identifies himself
Isaac suddenly realizes that he's given
his blessing to the wrong son he says
who is the one who hunted game brought
it to me and I partook of all when you
had not yet come and I blessed him
indeed he shall remain blessed right she
doesn't take back the blessing so why
first why did I saw Isaac actually
require Esau to go hunting and then cook
him a meal it's a weird sort of
condition second why didn't take up just
go to his dad and say I deserve the
better blessing because I'm a long term
thinker and Esau short-term thinker the
oddest part is that Isaac doesn't
reverse the blessing after he's deceived
he doesn't go oh I guess that your
brother stole the blessing I'm gonna
reverse this thing now because a
blessing given under false pretenses is
not effective right in the Torah if you
say the blessing for wine over a piece
of bread you haven't actually covered
your bases how logically speaking right
according to Jewish law blessings are
specific and they require specific
intent so if Isaac didn't intend to give
the blessing to Jacob then why was the
blessing it's still effective so let's
go back to the story for a second Isaac
orders he saw to go hunting to cook a
meal and prepare it for him that request
isn't actually about a meal right
because Rebekah can cook a meal for him
what Isaac is actually doing is asking
Esau to prepare the meal because he
wants Esau to show him that he can be
more than the hunter that he can
actually think about the future cooking
a meal at least shows some forethought
right you actually have to cook it you
have to you have to figure out what
ingredients you need you have to prepare
it and then you have to give it away all
Esau needs to do is add the elements
before word thing
because he's aggressive right Isaac is
thinking about the future of his family
and of the Jewish people by extension
and so Isaac says to Esau listen I know
that you're a fighter I know you can
protect yourself and defend yourself but
can you think ahead and that's what he's
saying to Esau in Isaac's eyes by
contrast Jacob has a long way to go
right cuz Isaac is a for Isaac sees
Jacobs a forward thinker but Jacob is
always in the Bible seen as sort of a
weaker character in terms of defending
himself right he's much more submissive
he's certainly less brusque he is
certainly less aggressive he thinks in
advance but he's not tough enough
so when Jacob shows up wearing Esau skin
Isaac doesn't know what to think
he doesn't know who this is is this Esau
who is finally coming around and
thinking ahead
or is this Jacob doing the unthinkable
actually braving the possibility of his
dad getting mad at him using whatever
means are necessary in order to protect
himself and his future in the end here's
the point I think doesn't actually care
whoever this is whether it's Esau or
Jacob gets the blessing why because this
person has demonstrated both inattention
to self-defense and attention to the
immediate and also inattention to the
future you have to do both right if you
sacrifice the present completely in
favor of the future that's no good but
if you sacrifice the future in favor of
the present that's no good either and
that's the theme here that's the theme
Jacob is supposed to be the model for
human beings and in the Bible and in
Torah Jacob is the model for the Jewish
man right he's considered in each Tom
meaning up sort of a whole man
well I because he thinks of the present
and he also thinks of the future and
that's what that story is all about Esau
by contrast only thinks of the present
and never thinks of the future and that
has some political ramifications for
today okay
well that ends our week here on the
podcast but good news for you there are
two additional hours of this show coming
up a little bit later on we'll do some
mail bagging we have a lot more content
this is why you should subscribe over
daily wire.com slash subscribe it makes
a great gift so go check that out right
now
otherwise you'll see you're on Monday
have a wonderful weekend i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
you
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director Pablo white house key
edited by Adam Tsai events audio is
mixed by Mike Romina hair and makeup is
by Jess well alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the ben shapiro show is a
daily wired production copyright daily
wire 20 19 on the matt walsh oh we're
not just discussing politics we're
talking culture faith family all of the
things that are really important to you
so come join the conversation
[Music]
you